you want to get really wealthy I made
several multiple six figures one year
and we lived in a $700 a month apartment
yes
biggest money mistake I made in my life
is investing in things that I don't
understand identity is the governor on
our lives it's the invisible force that
no one understands and once they do
understand and get a hold of their life
to change
Juanes or get a mentor what's up belief
nation it's Evan I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so today
let's learn from one of the best ed my
Lett and some of his best advice on how
to get rich mentor me Eddie
[Music]
you
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one pay yourself first financially my
formula is this and you're they're gonna
hear this because there's all this stuff
on social media about baro baro baro
baro first off the bible says oh no man
nothing so I didn't get rich by creating
debt and I could just tell you that I
don't care about what type of debt you
have but the one thing financially is
you do not want to borrow money if you
can minimize it against a depreciating
asset if you borrow money for something
that's going to appreciate like a home
or an investment property I'm pretty
cool with that although I still think
you should be careful with a debt but I
see far too many people borrowing money
against something that depreciates like
cars that they don't need to have just
to impress other people right or close
they don't need to be wearing and so
don't on credit cards don't borrow money
against stuff that goes down in value as
much as you can't the second thing is
live below your means any person
listening this can get financially
independent you have to pay yourself
first so believe it or not as crazy as
it sounds when I was broke I still found
a way to pay myself save $25 save $50
because if you can't save money when
you're making a little bit of money you
are not going to save money when you
make more money you think you will but
you won't you continued to spend it and
so there was literally a year when I
started to make money you want to get
really wealthy I made several multiple
six figures one year and we lived in a
$700 a month apartment I just saved and
saved and saved and saved because my
confidence and business came from my
ability to acquire and save money over
time which took me a while but to me
peace of mind is saving and cash cash is
king not enough people are obsessed with
saving cash and so live below your means
don't borrow money against stuff that
depreciate and save money and here's a
biggie start reading about money start
to familiarize yourself pick up some
books on finance start to know what
you're talking about the thing that
scares me the most is seeing people who
don't save money it blows my mind I
rarely do it anymore
but when we go to the mall on the
weekend and I'm watching people walking
out there were six seven bags and I'm
thinking my god like you don't need all
this stuff wouldn't that be cool to put
that $200 a month away in savings
someday for your children's college
someday for your retirement someday to
buy your dream house you're the best
thing of living here of living at the
ocean or have
jet or other material things I have is I
own them all there's no mortgage on this
home there's no mortgage at my Idaho
place there's no mortgage on my jet
there's no debt on any of my cars now it
hasn't always been that way
but the way I got there was by saving a
bunch of money when all my buddies were
blowing theirs on stuff to impress other
people that gets dated anyways right and
so stuff you buy that you think will
impress other people who's really only
cool for the first or second time you
wear it or use it anyways right and so
be really careful about that I love the
auto-pay idea that's paying yourself
first
rule number two invest in things you
understand yes biggest money mistake I
made in my life is investing in things
that I don't understand and weird like
stocks yeah stocks I bought that I knew
nothing about that I heard on at CNBC I
should buy or having some guy the one
things I like about your real estate
deals it's straightforward it's it's
it's simple it's easy to understand if
you present me a deal now and I can't
regurgitate it back to you real quick in
some simple form I'm not investing in it
I need to at least understand what it is
I'm investing in yeah even if even if
you miss something you're willing to
miss something I miss something yeah
I've missed so many things yeah so if I
can't understand it or it's too
complicated and I can't repeat it back
to you pretty quickly you lost me yeah
what was so what's the biggest loss you
had in not following that advice would
you buy one I bought I bought Yahoo
stock at about I don't remember 75 or 80
bucks a share and I'm talking like when
I had about 3 million bucks I put like
800 grand in there and I think I ended
up selling it in like 17 about
citigroup's why would you buy that I
think in the 70s or 80s I could exact
dollar US and then like after I learned
that lesson uh 140 grand yeah then I no
no you lost seven hundred and then I'm
giving you two more biggies second one I
did is I bought citi bank stock Sam
Group stock at like fifty four dollars a
share yeah 2008 which that was about
seven hundred thousand dollars worth of
that and I think I sold it at two fifty
two dollars and fifty cents
is when I finally sold it because I
heard they were going to be the next day
IG yeah their work to honey and then the
third one is stuff you talk about I
bought a residential real estate
property that did not provide any
revenue did not provide any equity for
me that was a what do you call it it
would be like a trophy property like hey
I'm a big shot the big time about one of
those that wasn't that long ago either
and that was a property that I wasn't
gonna use wasn't getting leveraged out
of didn't generate revenue I didn't know
anything about the market I was buying
and I just wanted to look like a big
shot and I think I lost two and a half
million on that house and that wasn't
that long ago that's just a few years
ago so I've still made some mistakes in
my life
but though those are probably the
biggest lost by that house on one deal
was probably that house I lost to have
already made maybe I lost three million
on that rule number three master the art
of persuasion I got to persuade people
you do how did you learn how to persuade
people so effectively to buy your
services and be part of your team when
there's marketing and branding and
commercials and everyone else is trying
to do the same for them what is your key
to persuasion without being sleazier
sales you like the most sales men like I
can't stand that right like they blink
three times that's a buying signal go
for the jugular or whatever I can't
stand that stuff so persuasion anything
so if you want to persuade your children
if you want to persuade someone to take
a look at your faith if you want to
persuade someone in business if you want
to persuade someone to help you in
anything or help them in anything it's
real simple for me
monster belief and so you can't transfer
to me that which you're not experiencing
yourself right so you can't give me a
people always trying to cope with a
magic word the magic clothes the magic
this and there are words you shouldn't
shouldn't use in persuasion no question
about it right there are think there are
words that are more effective in other
words and clearly to be successful in
any business you need to know what those
words are in your business both the best
persuaders the best motivators the best
speakers the best physicians the best
school teachers the best parents are
incredible persuaders and what they do
is they come from a monster place of
conviction and belief that they can
transfer you to because people respond
- energy much more than they do words
they respond to what they feel not what
they hear and see here and see a real
low-level influencers energy spirit
transfer of energy is what people
respond to and so I'm cognizant all the
time of getting in a state of total
belief and certainty about what it is
that I'm gonna represent or speak if I'm
speaking on stage about a particular
topic and then transferring that energy
into people and that seems generic or
hokey but it's actually what great
persuaders do in fact if you're listen
to this you think of anybody that you
know who's incredibly persuasive they
may have great words they probably do
but it's something you feel from them
right and that's the difference between
a great doctor and a so-so doctor great
doc says here's the prescription you're
out of here another one is these kind of
work or not I don't know the other one
you leave there feeling that you're
going to be healed selling you're in
good hands you feel their certainty you
feel their confidence saying when you
hear a speaker if you're buying real
estate from somebody but it's not just
buying things it's a great pastor in a
church a great person if you do TM who's
taught you TM it's there's certainty
it's the energy you feel and so for me
it's always getting to I have to really
believe what I'm saying I have to really
feel it to transfer to rule number four
shift your identity identity is the
governor on our lives it's the invisible
force that no one understands and once
they do understand and get a hold of
their life can change and so not only if
you don't get a hold of this will these
outward conditions of your life keep
being exactly the same but it's you
could behave differently could do all
the work not you could be thinking great
thoughts but you are going to get out of
your life you're gonna be the most
powerful force in the world I think is
to be consistent with the concepts ideas
and worth that you hold for yourself you
will get that out of your life what you
will tolerate okay the deeper part of
that is identity and so identity is very
much like a thermostat sitting on a wall
right this is important once that
temperature is set at a certain degree
everything in the world externally can
hit it and you will find a way to get
that temperature so even in this house
let's say it's set at 80 degrees if we
opened up all the doors and cold air
just the worst things in life the
blizzard or of life came in the
thermostat will pick the heater on and
it will regulate this room back to 80
degrees the reverse is also true it's a
super hot day great things are happening
in your
life is getting hotter and hotter and
hotter if you're at 80 degrees that
internal thermostat will find a way over
a window of time to cool your life right
back down to 80 degrees again so the key
the secret key is to be able to shift
that identity 90 120 so some of the ways
strategies to do that are very simple
one is if I let's just say financially
you're a 200-degree or and I'm an
80-degree or if I'm in your proximity
over and over and over and over again
you will heat my identity up somewhere
in between mine and yours to 150 degrees
same in Fitness same and everything so
the more you can layer in multiple
people the stronger and stronger that
forces so that changes our thermostat
through Association it's a huge huge
huge huge thing people say you are who
the five people who you hang around this
is why they adjust your thermostat
that's number one second way you can
change your identity is through doing
short bursts of something in a window of
time you've not done them before and
they change the thermostat temperature
permanently almost like a water line in
the pool so if it's a certain in the gym
certain amount in the gym or a certain
amount of phone calls in your business
or a certain amount of appointment you
make a certain amount of money
oftentimes you're never the same again
you've seen this when your own net worth
I've seen it in mind that became a point
where I made a leap in a short window I
was never really the same again I could
go back a little bit but not back where
I was before
so it's activity or successes
achievements in short bursts of time and
rule number five the last one before
very special bonus clip is rely on your
habits here's the thing that I get asked
all the time how did you stay motivated
all the time people ask me that all the
time and the answer is I didn't and
neither did you to become successful the
separator in life is really important
you'll think the most inspired motivated
person wins not not really it's the
person who can work on the day's they're
not inspired and motivated it's what do
you do when you're not feeling great
what do you do when it's not your best
day how do you do that carries you
through is rituals and habits so when
you're fatigued when you're tired when
you're under pressure you react
reflexively and so successful people
rely on habits and rituals not just
their inspiration and motivation level
of course we're both professionals and
being motivated inspired but that's not
every day every minute and so what do I
do I work on the days because my habits
and rituals carry me through and so
for me here's how I look at my life in
my day if I can control the first 30
minutes of my day and the last 30
minutes of my day I have a whole lot
better chance of the middle of my day
being controlled and so I'm a freak
about the first 30 minutes of every day
it's really about the first 45 minutes
and I'm obsessive about the last 45
minutes of every single day that gives
me some illusion in my mind and measure
of control the other thing it does it
delivers to me habits and rituals that
serve me that I do every day that are
consistent it gives me comfort in stormy
times that ocean out there is raging at
the top right now right the waves are
crashing at the bottom of that ocean
it's completely calm at the bottom of
that ocean is the habitual part of the
water right it's the it's the it's the
part of the war that stays the most
consistent that's why it's so calm okay
so when you see someone out of control
their emotions are up and down all the
time this is someone who is without
rituals and habits successful people
have those and so they do and so it
keeps me calm it keeps me comfortable
I've got a really special bonus clip
from Ed on how to bring real value to
people that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the three
point landing questions time to move
from just watching another video to
taking action in your life or business
and if you're feeling bold leave your
answers in the comments below here we go
question number one what shift do you
need to make to your identity number two
how will you pay yourself first and
number three what habits do you need to
rely on better
the reason that I think my stuff has
grown and I'm not trying to be
braggadocious in this regard my contents
good like my content and stuff that can
really affect you and change you I'm not
gonna tell you 1,100 times to get you
money I'm not gonna tell you to be kind
1,100 times and just repeat myself or
binary and all this stuff the guy's just
keep repeating themselves it's just it's
mindless information I don't even
understand how they have following to be
honest with you it's like I've heard you
say this same thing 2,000 different
times whereas I'm trying to keep my
content fresh relevant inspirational but
also strategic that's not knocking
people it's just I think you do this
very well like if you're gonna be in the
space really bring value to people you
know I mean if people are gonna follow
you give them value and inspiration for
the the privilege of them following you
so I feel an obligation to try to create
stuff daily when I can to move someone's
life forward
if you want more ed mileage check at the
top motivation for 2019 video I made on
him the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
successful people and wealthy people
have a subtle distinction they don't
look at price they look at worth
identity is the governor on our lives